Ukraine is vitally dependent on U.S
weapons as it wages the
counter-offensive that now appears to be
prompting Russia to withdraw from the
key provincial capital of Hassan will
American Support continue if Republicans
wield more power in Congress or will
they rally once again around America
first
Republican leaning toward its
isolationism and especially supporters
of former president Trump have said
there need to be limits to U.S support
for Ukraine even Joe Biden's Democrats
say Kiev should signal more willingness
to negotiate with Russia so we're asking
after the midterms could U.S support for
Ukraine Wayne
foreign
[Music]
a very warm welcome to to the point it's
a pleasure to introduce our guests
beginning with Laura Von Daniels she is
head of the research division the
Americas at the berlin-based think tank
swp
and it's also a great pleasure to greet
Matthew carnichnig he is Chief Europe
correspondent for Politico
and joining us remotely from Moscow is
Michelle tuman who is diplomatic
correspondent for the German weekly DEET
site and Michelle if I can begin
straight away with you and I'd like to
try to understand this news coming in
about Hassan we're being told that the
Russian defense minister has ordered
troops to leave her son which was of
course the only Regional Capital that
Russia had captured in the early days of
the war and held so what are you hearing
there are Russians acknowledging that
this is a serious reverse
well they are clearly not acknowledging
that this is a defeat or a serious
diverse they are describing it here on
stay TV and the Minister of Defense
himself and uh the uh person in charge
of its General Surah Wiki they all
describe it as a tactical new way of
Defending what they have achieved and
what they have conquered
um I I think it is it is a step to
consolidate
um actually and it is they are
withdrawing to the other side of the
neighbor River
to which is more easy to defend and
which will make it difficult for Ukraine
to continue the offensive as they did
before
it could be not just a tactic but a
trick some have speculated on that
well of course it's it's they keep
everybody guessing about what they are
going to do about
um he had a son since quite a while and
that is of course part of the tactic
um it is fairly possible that there will
be some Russian soldiers militia hiding
in the city and
disguised as civilians and then shoot at
Ukrainian troops that is that is
possible of course but I think the bulk
of and that is also what we can see from
satellite pictures the bulk of the
Russian troops actually withdraw at this
point in time Matthew would that
represent a withdrawal from this very
important provincial capital would that
uh change the calculus of the war as a
whole
I don't think we really we really know
yet I think it would definitely
give a strong sort of impetus to the
ukrainians to keep on going and you know
this is is clearly what we've heard from
zielinski in his in his daily videos
that he that he that he sends out that
he's really trying to continue to Rally
the ukrainians behind this war effort
and he's done so with with great success
so I mean this is something that they've
methodically been working on for the
past several weeks and and months and
they already took the northern city of
hockey but now they're they're uh looks
like succeeding and and taking and you
have to wonder well what what's next I
mean it is it zelinsky was joking a
couple of days ago maybe not joking
about spending the summer back in Crimea
next next year so I think you know they
want to keep on going whether the United
States and others want them to keep on
going at this clip is is another a
question
Laura president zielinski needed a real
sign of progress not only to improve
morale amongst his own citizens but also
to reassure his allies that a victory is
possible do you think that the
developments in in her son will do that
I think it helps him in making Ukraine
look like a winner with a serious
chances being a winner in the end not
losing too much territory and whatever
we're finally then in the end be an
agreement hopefully a peace agreement
and it will immensely happen in the U.S
debate I think because as as we've heard
already in the past few weeks there are
debates now about how much this whole
War costs the U.S how much the public
needs to spend on Ukraine or shouldn't
be spending on Ukraine this question was
raised by Republicans essentially
and uh so it will help zelenski to look
like a winner like someone to bet on
and as you uh as you say the support has
been enormous Western weapons have
played a crucial role in helping
Ukrainian forces as they wage they're
counter-offensive and not only around
Hassan the U.S leads that effort with a
massive 18 billion dollars in weapons
packages since the War Began
an apartment building in Ruins and
mikolayev the Russian army repeatedly
attacked the region in southern Ukraine
its troops are trying to hold out but
their Weaponry isn't enough
above all we need artillery that can
strike up to 300 kilometers away
and an air defense system basic
equipment for any army in this world
that wants to move forward
but the Ukrainian counter-offensive in
the South has made good progress
recently
High Mars missile launches from the US
are crucial for this the mobile weapon
system can fire multiple missiles within
a very short time hitting targets as far
away as 80 kilometers
in addition to miss our launchers the US
is also supplying armored vehicles and
howitzers more than 18 billion dollars
worth of weapons and equipment since the
Russian invasion according to the
Pentagon
the U.S Congress has approved a total of
60 billion dollars in Aid to Ukraine so
far according to the New York Times
according to a report the United States
has committed twice as much as EU
countries
what else can Ukraine expect from the
USA in the future
and let me pass that question directly
to Matthew Matthew your newspaper
Politico reported a few days ago on
mounting anxiety in Ukraine preceding
the midterms what's your take do you see
reason to believe uh in fact that U.S
support for Ukraine could Wane as a
result of of the elections
well I think there are two things going
on here one is that the Republicans who
are about to take control of the House
of Representatives are going to want to
have more of a say in what this help
looks like does help this Aid is going
to be scrutinized probably a bit more
than it has been up to now a lot of
people would say well there's nothing
wrong with that this is sort of the
normal parliamentary process I don't
think that the Congress is going to
start blocking this aid but I think that
there will be more questions about what
is being sent there and why and
especially why isn't Europe doing more
because what the United States has done
so far is I think double all of the
other uh help that's been put forth
combined and especially when you get to
the military help which as we just heard
has been absolutely essential to this
effort you know people are going to
start asking questions in Washington but
I think there's just one other aspect to
this is if the ukrainians continue to
succeed which many of us hope they will
how how does this end and at what point
um do they need to start thinking about
you know negotiations and I think that
there is a lot of uh unease about that
question in Washington and I want to
come back to that in just a second but
let's go first uh to Michelle in Moscow
and U.S Security Services reported in
the week prior to the midterms on a very
significant uptick in Russian
disinformation uh on U.S uh internet
platforms and social media
how's Moscow reacting now to the
election result given the fact that
those efforts didn't necessarily uh wind
up getting the trumpist candidates that
Moscow prefers elected
well it was interesting to watch Russian
stay TV
um yesterday the 60-minute propaganda
show people sitting around and being
actually very disappointed about the
election results because they have
clearly expected uh Trump candidates and
make America great again candidates to
win all over the place this did not
happen and this of course we need to be
clear about that from the Russian
perspective the Russia party in America
is the America first
group in the political Spectrum so um
that is their hope has been disappointed
the question now is of course
and this is what Matthew is just
indicated that there might be questions
asked about more help for Ukraine and
this is now what they are their Hope on
what I think is that in in general
Russian influence on American elections
has been sharply diminished and I I
don't think that there was any strong
influence whatsoever thank you very much
very interesting um Laura it's not only
make American great again Republicans
who have been questioning open-ended
support uh for Ukraine we also saw a
letter issued by Progressive Democrats
which was subsequently retracted but
also essentially raising the same
question would you say that war
weariness is setting in in the United
States I think we now really need to
look closely at who is coming into
Congress and in what function so look at
the Committees the relevant committees
look if there's an uptick in the Maga or
sort of populist fraction in in
parliamentarians in the U.S or not
because they will be the people in in
the Committees that decide on continuing
resolutions any kind of funding for
Ukraine and that is the essential part
so don't listen to the rhetorics but
look at their decisions and perhaps
leadership also which which direction
they're pointing their own fraction and
that makes much more sense I think and
that's probably what ukrainians are
doing right now
Matthew we've also seen and heard that
the U.S government has pressure has been
pressuring Kiev to display more openness
toward diplomatic talks with Moscow do
you think that Washington really expects
president zielinski to sit down soon at
a table with Vladimir Putin
I I think it depends on the trajectory
of the war and if the ukrainians
continue to succeed in taking back their
territory
um at some point you know the question
is going to be asked how far are you
going to go you know zelinsky as I said
is talking about taking back Crimea
which is Ukrainian territory which is
fair enough but I think that many people
in the west are going to be asking
especially in Western Europe and Paris
and and Rome you know well you know how
far are we going to let him go here
because there is concern about
triggering a wider a wider conflict
um so I I think Washington is also aware
of these of these concerns and everybody
you know wants Ukraine to win in the
west but they also want this war to end
so there is a bit of tension here nobody
so far in the past months has been able
to give me a convincing uh prediction or
explanation of how this war ends
Michelle Russian officials uh have said
that Moscow is open to negotiations and
they blame kiev for stonewalling
president zielinski however says it is
not possible to negotiate with Vladimir
Putin in good faith is he right
um well we have to look back at how the
process of negotiation started in the
beginning of the year Kiev made lots of
suggestions
um
how to settle the conflict and it was
Putin who rejected all of that
um it is a diplomatic trait now
um in here in Moscow to display this
Readiness of for negotiations uh to
every visitor who comes here from the
global South
um or to let Minister lavrov and he will
do that on the upcoming G20 Summit again
to display Readiness we want to
negotiate if we see look back at the
history of Russia's negotiation
readiness
in this conflict we realized that there
is no Readiness at all
um they they have their clear-cut uh War
aims War Golds which is to take control
of all of Ukraine and if that is not
possible to keep control of parts of
Ukraine and destruct the rest of it
um so and and I think they will not
renegotiate basically this aim but of
course it makes sense in the Diplomatic
Arena
um to to be ready for negotiations
especially if uh president zelenski
appears to be hard-nosed which I think
is a mistake rhetorically
to us laypeople Laura it can seem uh
somewhat paradoxical to think about
conducting negotiations while fighting
is still ongoing
um is it nonetheless the right thing to
do it's certainly with the U.S
Administration is also doing I mean
there's been reports by The Wall Street
Journal The Washington Post that the
National Security advisor in the U.S
Jake Sullivan is talking both to Moscow
and Kiev and I think it makes a whole
lot of sense and it's important that
these information channels are kept open
but I also agree that it's probably not
the right moment yet to really trust the
Russians on
willingness to negotiate I think part of
the truth is also
that sanctions and all the negative
effects on the Russian economy probably
they have to buy it a bit more until
there's a readiness
let's now take a deeper dive on what the
election results in the U.S could mean
for Ukraine and Republicans are
certainly eager to make the most of
their midterm gains in Congress to throw
obstacles in the way of President Biden
so will they rally once again around
America first and if so what could that
mean for Ukraine's support
if Mitch McConnell the U.S Senate's
Republican caucus leader had his way the
U.S would Supply even more weapons
including longer range ones to Ukraine
congresswoman Liz Cheney points out we
need to be doing more faster in terms of
what we're providing to the ukrainians
we're not going to go back to the days
of isolationism but there have been
other statements especially from Trump
loyalists in the party
Kevin McCarthy Republican leader in the
House of Representatives recently
suggested there would no longer be a
blank check for Ukraine in the case of a
recession
far-right representative Marjorie Taylor
green has accused President Biden of
giving hard-earned U.S tax dollars to a
country fighting a war it cannot win
America first as former president Trump
slogan he could run again in 2024.
safe and glorious I will probably have
to do it again
how strong is trumpism in the U.S
and let me ask you uh to answer that
question Matthew was Donald Trump The
Biggest Loser on Tuesday and
if his star is waning can trumpism
survive Donald Trump
well the answer to the first question is
yes he was the biggest loser and yet uh
trumpism could still survive and thrive
we've already heard him blaming other
people as he always does when something
goes bad for him and I think in the
coming days and weeks we're going to see
if he succeeds in turning this defeat
into
um another victory for himself by
pointing fingers at other people and
claiming that he's the only one who can
really continue to lead this party and
take it to the promised land and he's
going to do that by running again for
president and he's announced that he's
going to make some sort of big decision
on the 15th of November
as we heard in that report uh Laura
Republicans are hardly United and in
fact there is also a a group in the
party that is traditionally moderate and
internationalists so how strong is the
American first faction and do you think
that the midterm results are likely to
Spur it on or possibly restrain it
well we've seen that more centrists
moderate candidates have been gaining
also in the Republican side and that
less of the Maga isolationist fraction
has been as successful as expected
and and he also goes for the election
deniers they weren't as
successful as expected initially so I
think
um with the right leadership I guess
there's a chance that they uh turn more
towards the traditional Republican line
and the big question here will be the
main competitive for Donald Trump Ron
DeSantis where is he positioning himself
see a lot of raucous infighting in the
Republican caucus going forward and
mightn't that distract them from
focusing on the Ukraine issue
I think we could see a lot of fighting
in the leadership of the party about who
should run should it be DeSantis should
it be Trump the problem is is that once
Trump announces he's going to have the
base behind him the base is very
dedicated to Trump and I don't think
that's going to change I don't think
that DeSantis is going to be able to
change that in the coming weeks so it
would really require Trump to step back
which it doesn't look like he's going to
do on the other hand everybody in the
leadership of the Republican Party
understands that they've lost the last
several elections with Trump at the at
the top and it's not just this midterm
election they lost the presidency
obviously they lost the senate in 2020
and they lost the house in 2018. so it
is true that he still galvanizes the
base of the party but when you're
talking about national elections or even
Statewide elections where you need to
build coalitions and draw in Centrist
voters moderate voters as we've heard
are playing an Ever more important role
in these elections Trump is not the guy
you want to be leading the ticket
Michelle Beyond questioning military aid
to Ukraine what else might uh newly
empowered republicans in Congress do to
throw wrenches in the works of President
Biden's foreign policy
well what they can do of course is they
can ask how much money is going to be
spent on on aid for Ukraine both
military and other financial aid and of
course what they could do easily is to
ask why do not the Europeans spend more
and then maybe especially Germany
because Germany has come under Fire
in the past months about their financial
contribution and we're not able to
deliver uh in in in in or at least
publicly make clear that they're
actually not uh delivering uh enough and
um so that is the possibility but in
general what I see coming out of these
elections is that the Trump Camp has
clearly not won and that there's a clear
majority in Congress
um both on both sides and so this is a
bipartisan issue to support Ukraine and
this is why I don't expect a reversal
there might be more bumps ahead but it's
not a reversal of U.S policy towards
Ukraine Laura as Michelle just mentioned
it has really been a refrain and by the
way not only since these midterm
elections but really since the Trump
presidency that Europe needs to become
more independent of the US that it needs
to prepare for a future in which
American Support might not be as
forthcoming as it has in the past but do
you see any real signs that that is
happening
I think there's a lot of commitment
with regards to Nato and and sort of
support uh in in the transatlantic
relationship but certainly there will be
discussions on contributions also from
the Europe European side and it's now
um High time for Europeans I think to to
Signal also to the Biden Administration
but also to Republicans that they're
willing to take on more responsibility
and it's not just on on Ukraine it will
be on the China question as well it will
be in other areas in the indo-pacific
where the Biden Administration and also
the Republican party they they have
great expectations of of what we are
supposed to
contribute I think to security and
yeah into our own stability here in
Europe for sure Matthew you also
mentioned that point uh that indeed
there has been pressure on Europe and uh
that certainly uh that is a lesson that
Europe could be learning from these
midterms When The War Began and the U.S
came through with so much support for
Ukraine there was a lot of rejoicing in
Europe that the U.S is back uh as it
were would you say that could prove to
be a short-lived chapter
uh no I would say that the U.S never
left to be honest and if you look back
over the past you know 70 to 80 years
since World War II the U.S has always
been here they've always stepped into
the breach when Europe couldn't handle
its problems if you think about what
happened in Yugoslavia some of us are
old enough to remember the wars in
Yugoslavia I covered them the U.S played
a central role there in part because the
Europeans couldn't get their act
together and this is a replay of that
the stakes here are much greater I think
the United States the Europeans don't
like to hear this Remains the linchpin
for European security if you pull it out
the whole thing will collapse there's a
lot of infighting in Europe about you
know strategic autonomy how they could
build an army and all of these things
it's just it's not going to happen if
the United States disengages it would be
a catastrophe and I think even
Republicans understand this in the
United States Donald Trump might not
understand it but from an economic
perspective I think the Republicans
understand how important Europe remains
for the United States quick closing
round you know one word answer coming
back to our title after the midterms
could U.S support for Ukraine Wayne
Michelle
no I don't think it will Wane the U.S
will keep on supporting Ukraine for the
time being
Laura short-term yes long term we have
to see but it's more about the amounts
and not whether their support or not
that's it no
no thank you clear and short thank you
so much to all of you for being with us
today and thanks to you for for joining
in dear audience and please let us know
if you're watching us on YouTube what
you thought about the program send us
your comments we look forward to hearing
from you
thank you
[Music]